ciao buonasera dunque anch'io faccio
parte nella grande famiglia dei
diplomati nel 2000 sono arrivato a
milano dove non avevo la minima idea di
che cosa avrei fatto nella mia vita è
infatti quello che sono finito a fare è
stata credo la cosa più originale
le immagini che vedete alle mie spalle
poi me le spiego le farò scorrere più
avanti ci sono nella vita alcune scelte
che
ti vengono consigliate
e altre che le prende da solo mio padre
un giorno avevo 24 anni mi disse sandro
decidi che cosa vuoi fare nella tua vita
perché così non va bene avevo fatto
accademia belle arti avevo frequentato
da vivere a te frequentato e scienze
politiche con pessimi risultati bene
arriva a milano e decisi che il mio
lavoro sarebbe stato di entrare al
designer ora per quanto riguarda il
mondo del design
io ho una mia teoria
prima di tutto questa sera non ha
sentito parlare di creatività ossia lo
sentivo parlare in maniera un po così
vaga comunque insegno all'accademia di
belle arti fashion design a perugia
tutti gli anni faccio fare ai miei
studenti una raccolta di immagini
chiedendo che cosa per voi è bello un
cavallo una donna un'auto una cintura un
occhiale un gioiello quello che si ha
scorrono le immagini inutile che il
commento
queste sono alcune delle immagini che mi
hanno portato i miei studenti alcune in
realtà ce l'ho messo io perché mi
piacevano semplicità grafica alla
massima espressione di semplicità un
oggetto che ottenuto un blocco di
materiale unico
poi abbiamo visto una macchina per
scrivere purtroppo non signore bene ma
rappresenta il massimo dell essenzialità
e nera semplicissima con i tasti molto
molto semplici il m m niente di
particolarmente speciale però un oggetto
che a chi l'ha scelto è piaciuto
benissimo immagini di un paesaggio un
altro paesaggio ancora una giostra la
mia città perugia anche io adoro questa
immagine rappresenta la centralità la
centralità di è bello che cosa intendo
io per bello qualcosa è bello nel
momento in cui scatena in voi un
emozione ok è una donna bella una
macchina bella e scatena in voi un
emozione capitemi è bello significa
quella macchina e filante mi dà l'idea
di qualcosa che che sia veloce quella
donna è bella perché mi piace
nel caso nei suoi lineamenti la
centralità di tutto ciò è l'emozione se
scatena in voi un emozione quella cosa è
bella
e cos'è chi è che riesce a portare
avanti
purtroppo noi non per tanti anni questa
idea di sentimento di bello di
creatività
il bambino questa immagine sono io da
piccolo e me la sono messa nel mio
laboratorio in centro a perugia nel
quale disegno progetto realizzo occhiali
sartoriali per fattoria ne intendo
l'occhiale esattamente come il vostro
sarto di realizza la camicia cioè volete
con i bottoni rossi con le cuciture
verdi con il collo all'inglese botton
down come preferite
io vi realizzò gli occhiali questa
immagine perché rappresenta per me il
massimo stato di felicità
qui purtroppo non si vede ma io ho
legato ad un braccio un nastrino con un
palloncino per me in quel momento era la
cosa più bella quel palloncino è una
cosa più bella che potesse avere perché
perché scatenava in me un'emozione
ricordate vera questa cosa qualcosa è
bello se scatena e un'emozione questo
perché per arrivare a dire che bisogna
iniziare tornare a realizzare cose belle
vi prego realizziamo oggetti belli case
belle chiese belle telefoni ben ci sono
tanti oggetti bibbia non è che lo mette
in dubbio ma noi cresciamo lasciamo
crescere viviamo in un paese splendido
la mia città perugia io l'adoro
mio padre mi ha insegnato sin da piccola
ad alzare gli occhi e mi diceva sempre
guardati guarda in alto cercare di
vedere tutto non guardare solo al se ad
altezza occhio io così ha sviluppato la
mia sensibilità per il bello e mi sono
reso conto che quello che per me era
bello era era quello che
che suscitare emozioni emozioni brividi
requa ecco così facendo ho intrapreso la
mia carriera
cioè ho iniziato a disegnare occhiali
perché perché nelle grandi aziende
il bello purtroppo non c'è ma c'è ma non
c'è non puoi mettere il sentimento non
puoi mettere te stesso in un oggetto che
sta disegnando e progettando io quando
progetto i miei cari ci metto il cuore
ci metto veramente il cuore lo faccio
con passione la cosa più bella che io
possa fare quello che vorrei che questa
chiacchierata venisse fuori che stasera
è proprio questo se dovete fare un
lavoro cercate di fare il lavoro che vi
piace
che dire al trasporto dovete andare a
lavorare con con gioia capisco che non è
una cosa semplice ma se vi impegniate
siete sforzate ce la fate
io sono arrivato alla europeo con l'idea
che avrei disegnato mobili
poi in realtà sono infinito a disegnare
occhiali non perché per una casualità
perché ho progettato nella mia vita
prima e stata fatta una intervista che
mi è stato chiesto che cosa consigli ad
un ragazzo che inizia ora che entra il
mondo del lavoro
io consiglio riprogettare la propria
vita progettare la propria vita non
significa schematizzare imbrigliarla in
uno schema matematico significa mettere
le idee ha posto una dietro l'altra
tassellino dietro l'altro che cosa
voglio fare voglio fare questo quindi
devo studiare vuoi sapere io sono uscito
dalla grande azienda nella quale
disegniamo occhiali che già sapevo dove
comprare i materiali come poter definire
un occhiale
come come poter montare le aste dove
poter comprare in minuterie eccetera
eccetera
quindi ho progettato la mia idea e
l'omessa quasi su carta e poi l'ha
portata nel real e lo portava nel reale
in questo laboratorio che nel centro
storico di perugia
quando parliamo nell'artigianato a me
mi viene sempre in mente un laboratorio
un po sporco puzzolente amici che hanno
laboratori pelletteria quindi lavorano
con le cose bene
l'artigianato non è solo quello
l'artigianato per me è questo per me
l'artigianato essere artigiano essere un
sardo significa avere un laboratorio nel
quale quando il cliente che non chiamo
cliente perché non mi piace perché è più
un amico continente si accomoda sul
divano faccia quattro chiacchiere mi
dice ma sì io sono più sportivo no sono
avvocato vado in udienza sono spazierà
c'è bisogno degli occhiali resistenti è
il rapporto che c'è con con chi crea
l'oggetto sentito parlare questa sera
più di una volta
c'è bisogno di una persona dietro a
qualcosa ecco io non sono dietro ma sono
davanti
cioè proprio lì mi prendo prendo per
mano il cliente il mio amico e cerco di
portarlo piano piano anche un po verso
quello che preferisco perché alcune
volte dagli occhiali per non ti sta
proprio tanto bene forse è meglio che lo
facciamo un pochino l'occhiale bianco
quale all'occhiale bianco e forse è
meglio che lo facciamo così ok
l'artigiano moderno non è più quello che
sta lì sporco e partigiano moderno
diciamo che sono io io mi definivo
all'inizio artigiano tecnologico come
vedete sotto alla mia fotografia da
bimbo
c'è una fresa controllo numerico quella
macchina
lavora a 0 0 1 di precisione
ringrazio mio padre ma sarà l'altro
aiutato a comprarla perché era aggeggio
che cosa abbastanza quindi l'artigianato
sì parliamo di artigianato ma cerchiamo
di inventarci all'artigianato cerchiamo
di essere creativi in quello che
facciamo
senonchè creatività e se non c'è il
senso del bello
per quanto mi riguarda non andiamo molto
lontano
l'italia sta vivendo un periodo un po
così io sono convinto che riprenderà
riprenderà molto velocemente ma in
realtà sta già riprendendo sintetizza le
fiamme si vedono in giro proprio perché
c'è la voglia c'è c'è la consapevolezza
che siamo una nazione bella di cose
belle di persone belle che sanno il
sorriso in faccia e che quando
realizzano qualcosa lo realizzano col
cuore
questo è quanto